in this lesson we're going to talk about
an important concept for the new sat and
that's the right triangle trigonometry
or oftentimes referred to as the
sohcahtoa
trig ratios so let's go through what
sohcahtoa represents and then we'll get
into some example problems to give you
some practice so first of all this
acronym kind of helps us to remember the
sine cosine and the tangent ratios and
what it is it's always going to be the
second letter divided by the third so in
this case it's the opposite over the
hypotenuse
when you're finding the sine
the cosine is the adjacent side over the
hypotenuse when you're finding the
cosine and the tangent is going to be
the opposite side divided by the
adjacent side so let's look at an
example so say you have a 3 four five
right triangle like this and you want to
find the sine of theta well sine is
opposite over hypotenuse so opposite is
going to be across that's three the
hypotenuse is across from the right
angle that's five so the sine is going
to be three-fifths if you want to find
the cosine cosine is adjacent which
means next to okay but not the
hypotenuse so the other side that's next
to that's four
over the hypotenuse that's going to be
five and then the tangent is going to be
the opposite side
over the adjacent side it's the opposite
of adjacent so that's going to be three
over four so those are your basic you
know trig ratios sine cosine and tangent
now you can also find the cosecant
secant and cotangent these are called
the reciprocal identities the cosecant
is really just the reciprocal of sine so
if you know the sine is three-fifths the
cosecant would be five-thirds
secant is one over cosine or the
reciprocal of cosine and cotangent is a
reciprocal of tangent now another
problem that kind of comes up on the sat
is this concept of the 90 minus the
angle 90 minus theta
and the idea here is that see if this
angle is 90 these two angles have to add
up to 90. so if this is theta this angle
over here is 90 minus theta so for
example like if this is 20 this has to
be 90 minus 20 or 70 because 70 plus 20
is 90 plus 90 is 180 all the angles in a
triangle add up to 180 right
so let's just say they ask us to find
the sine of 90 minus theta what we can
do is we can position ourselves at this
angle and think about the opposite over
hypotenuse so opposite is going to be 4
in this case and the hypotenuse is going
to be 5 so this is 4 fifths so if you
can just remember that these angles are
complementary or they add up to 90
degrees if this is theta this is 90
minus theta and you got it so let's go
through some examples
the first example says in a right
triangle one angle measures x degrees
where the tangent of x equals 5 12
what is the cosine of 90 minus x so go
ahead and pause the video see if you can
do this on your own and we'll go through
it together
so what i would do is i would draw a
right triangle like this
here's angle x
and this of course would then be 90
minus x
and it tells us that the tangent of this
angle
which is opposite
over adjacent
observer adjacent so that's a cross and
next to right and if we do the
pythagorean theorem a squared plus b
squared equals c squared or if we know
our pythagorean triples we can find the
hypotenuse here and that's going to be
13. so all i did was i did 5 squared
plus 12 squared equals c squared that's
25 plus 144 equals c squared 169 equals
c squared and if you take the square
root of both sides
you'll get 13 for that hypotenuse but
then it says you know what's the cosine
of 90 minus x that's this angle here so
we're positioning ourselves at the 90
minus x angle
cosine of course is adjacent over
hypotenuse so adjacent is next to
hypotenuse is 13. so the answer to this
question is going to be 5 13.
okay let's go to example number two so
here they give us this triangle with
angles m and n okay and it's a right
triangle and it says if the tangent of
angle m
is 0.7
what is the cotangent
of angle n okay now there's a couple
different ways you can do this problem
but let's just look so tangent
is
opposite over adjacent now 0.7 you could
write this as 7 10 right so the opposite
okay would be 7 the adjacent would be 10
and then if you do the pythagorean
theorem you can find this side here
across from the right angle the
hypotenuse the c side
but then it says what's the cotangent of
n so we're over here at angle n
okay and we know that cotangent is the
reciprocal of tangent so tangent is
going to actually be opposite over
adjacent that's ten sevenths
but cotangent is a reciprocal of tangent
so this is going to be seven tenths so
that's probably the way that i would
approach this problem just you know go
ahead and find the the sides position
yourself at the angle that you're
interested in and then you can figure
out what the ratio is from there so
again something definitely important to
understand for the sat that's right
triangle trig and the sohcahtoa acronym
so review this lesson if you need to
otherwise i'll see you in the next
lesson